abone ol
[Müzik]
az
önce de çok teşekkür ediyorum
arkadaşlar
[Müzik]
Gerçekten yararlandığımız ben çok ördüm
gördüğünüz yerler
var ya
[Müzik]
Selam
gençler çok daha çok daha büyük şeyler
farklı bir ortamda büyüyorlar u çok
Arkadaşlar
çok güzel
böyle mı
mı
bu hiçbirşey unutmamak lazım Ben de
geldik ayette
şahsiyetin girişimci o
[Müzik]
Sen
benden bir tavsiye ettim belki bir şey
söyledi
atıyorum
22 yaşındayım i
Allah
bugün işini gücünü bırakıp buradakiler
öğrenmeye geldi bir şeyler açısından
özellikle girişimcilik yapmak isteyen
arkadaşlar
hiçbir zaman
insanı o
[Müzik]
bir ayak aldım şu an Türkiye'de ve
dünyada en özel girişimciler olarak
gösteren insanlar aslında en zeki
insanlar arkadaşlar Zeki ev
defa düştüğünde onu defa ayağına olursa
o
[Müzik]
ne
olacaksa Bu pasta bir defa daha denirdi
ne olursa olsun
bir örnek var mı
[Müzik]
da her bir olumsuzlukta aralıklı
yapacağım kendi
kendine
iyi bak
[Müzik]
ve hızlı yaparken Ben mesela olduğunu
öğrenmek öğrenmeye çalışıyorum veya
hepinizin geliştirmeye çalışıyorum
bu çok önemli mi
[Müzik]
16'da bu
çalışmasını geliştirme olayları ya Boş
işlerle uğraşma uğraştım olayında
sadece faydalı olur
çünkü ciddi anlamda fark etmeye
başlıyorsun ya
[Müzik]
Ben 15 16 rahatlıkla vermesi
yuvarlayiniz aramış tasarım uygulama
yapmazsınız o
bu
başka bir şey
izlediğiniz Neyi tercih ettiğiniz sizin
hayatınızı kariyerinize belirledim Bakın
ben motivasyon için söyle buraya gelip
de arkadaşlar arkadaşlar şey diyorum o
[Müzik]
bir
arkadaşınıza Ananız Babanız dahi olsa
şu an
arkadaşım olarak binlerce kişiyle
çalıştık yaptık ve
[Müzik]
ya
neyse avrattan
n11 işte
muhafızları Belediyesi Gazi
Üniversitesi'nden gelirim
söylüyorum Okulu gördükten sonra
gördükten sonra o
bu kızlar şu aklından çıkarma Ne
yaparsınız gelecekte onu göreceğiz yani
şu ana kadar bize koyarsanız olarak şu
[Müzik]
bu 17 18 yaşındaki insanların top yazıp
söylüyorum 15 TL gibi bitirelim ağaçlar
içinde başladığımız biliyorum bize ilk
geldiğinde yaşam önemli nerede olduğunu
önemi yok hangi üniversiteden mezun
olduğum yok vesaire vesaire olayı
kendine kadar getirmiş Bu da
3'ü mi takip tercümanlı oh gelecek
bölümlere hepsi 99'u
[Müzik]